let's talk about this triller news
because i mean it's pretty incredible
you're 18 years old
and you are just named chief strategy
officer of the entire company
walk me through how this all kind of
happened first of all yeah of course so
um we started hearing like the
rumors about tick tock i'll say in the
media and news
and then with that we felt like it was
kind of like our innate responsibility
to go and find a place that would be
safe for
other creators ourselves and definitely
i mean the number one focus the people
that follow us and our supporters
so that started about three months ago
at the beginning we
wanted to possibly create our own app
we were thinking that would be the way
to go and then we met with the trailer
team
and they just were very forward thinking
there they listened to our ideas which
we haven't had
a lot of on other platforms so it's just
very refreshing what exactly
is triller so trailer is a music-based
platform
they're rolling out a lot of new things
uh that i will be overseeing as chief
strategy officer with the monetization
and with that um we're gonna be
enrolling a new live streaming platform
with uh monetization on that and as well
they have uh partnerships with uh many
labels including
universal warner and sony which allows
us to actually use that music without
having to pay any licensing fees
um as well we can actually use that
uh i guess editing tools on trailer
to create uh videos and post them on
other platforms without getting
copyrighted which is amazing
what exactly i mean will your
responsibilities entail you mention sort
of helping with the monetization
aspects you kind of walk me through what
your job is going to be yes oh i
definitely will be kind of like the
inside guy for the creators what we've
experienced as creators definitely feel
a little bit more comfortable
speaking to a fellow creator and
obviously i'm gonna care about
my content as a creator just as they
will so anytime they have concerns
uh they want improvements they have an
idea i'll be able to hear them out have
a conversation with them and then report
that back to the team
you're only 18 so do you feel like your
age
hurts you and getting people to take
this seriously do you think it helps
because you are so knowledgeable and you
are able to cultivate such a following
for yourself
someone from my generation we know
social media the best we grew up with it
and i think that uh with my four years
now of experience
on social media i started when i was 14.
i've just learned a lot and i'm able to
share that knowledge with
trailer was it just the rumblings of
tick tock possibly
going away that really solidified your
decision to do this it was the safety
concerns
uh as as be as a creator as someone that
cares for other creators
i wanted to make sure that all of our
supporters were in a place where their
data wasn't being shared
and same with the creators what does
this mean for your relationship with
tick tock i mean will you stop using the
app
completely um so to begin
uh we we want to spread awareness of
the move to triller so we still will be
like posting on tech talk every once in
a while because we want to
have you know the fans that are on there
know where we're going
as well as give them some of the
knowledge behind
why so but slowly and certainly we will
be you know
focusing a lot on uh trailer do you
feel bad at all because tick tock really
helped to catapult you to this
i mean i'll have a nice relationship
with the people at tick tock
well the thing is is tick tock wasn't
very open to hearing our ideas a lot of
the time
and um i feel like they were
usually either saying like no that can't
happen or they would say we would work
on it and it never came to be
so that's why when we talked to trailer
it was just such a refreshing feeling
so you tried to have this conversation
with people at tiktok about like privacy
concerns and what you wanted to see
change in the app or whatever definitely
changes in the app
more more along the lines of
monetization we know that uh griffin
and noah are going to be part of this
who else
from your group of tick tock friends are
you hoping to bring over
to triller i mean obviously all of them
but i think it's a very uh natural
movement griffin's right here with
hey hey how's it going it's going good
how are you
good it's a very exciting day oh hey
what's going on how are you
guys thank you yeah they'll be taking
advisor roles actually at trailer
um and then with the with the other
creators i mean
we we're just gonna keep spreading that
message of uh
where we should be and where we should
spend our time and we we hope they
follow
how will triller affect all the
different houses i feel like we're
always hearing about hype house and
sway lay so how do you see this playing
a role
in that i don't think it will affect it
in any negative way i think it will
benefit the houses to have uh
another platform to use are you part of
a house right now you're not
um not at the moment no so i mean i was
part of i guess you could say the og
sway house
um and i'm still like brothers with
every single person that is involved in
that we film content together but
i actually live in a house with jayden
hosler and love anthony right now
so bryce said recently that he thinks
some of
some of the og members will be coming
back to sway
are you included in that um
i mean i i have a house right now that i
love so
i it's not that i won't be filming with
them but
i guess we'll have to wait and see is
that a conversation that's constantly
happening though i think bryce really
wants me back he loves to talk about it
so
i'm just swinging
[Music]
what is the best part of fame so far uh
the best part
i mean i think it's like getting to meet
so many new people and as well like
getting to see all these people that
uh follow me and like my content in
person like when they
are freaking out or whatever it's just
so funny to me because it's like
why why like like crazy right and like i
almost like get just as excited as them
when they come up and like
are like oh let me take a photo because
i'm like okay yeah let's do it
because it's such a cool feeling to me
but uh i would say just meeting everyone
it's awesome yeah what about what's the
hardest part
the hardest part um i would say
it's like i think people
try to make you look bad a lot when
you're it when you're in a spotlight
and i think they try to like take things
you say and twist it
or they judge you harder for your
mistakes as if like they've never made
any
and i think that's definitely what makes
creators kind of go into a uh
i guess more like darker time in their
lives like
you see a lot of creators and they'll
post about like uh if it's either like
depression
or anxiety or uh any other feelings that
they're having in like
a lot of that stems from all these like
comments that they're getting on a daily
basis and
or dms that they're getting or hate
videos that they're getting um
and i just think that like you know
there's a difference between
joking around and like having a good
time with it when they start to go to
that like
extra step that's when it kind of like
it's hard have you experienced any of
that like do you feel anxiety
over the things that you post or the
comments that you're getting or have you
felt like depressed over
any hate that you've ever gotten i mean
i think
that i'm in a pretty good like mental
state where i'm able to handle it when i
was younger
like in that freshman year i quit social
media for three months
and then i started to realize like why
would i let those people
uh take away from me something i love
so it just kind of like got to the point
for me where i was like
okay you know what this this is what
comes with it this is this is kind of
like
uh the curse that comes with the gift
she say she gonna call me back i told
her call me rocky she say she's not
gonna call me that
what do the next five years look like
for you
um yeah no so definitely
number one like growing up my
entrepreneurial mindset
and uh the the companies that i'm
co-founding and a part of
uh that's definitely a 100 percent has
my main focus
and then after that it's uh keeping up
with my content
i really want to be able to you know
take over youtube
along with you know some of my friends
and
moving into different like parts of the
entertainment industry if it's acting
or working on my music and yet keep
keep expanding are you interested in
acting
uh yeah yeah for sure it's definitely
something that like
sparked my interest when i was younger
so i hope to eventually like
get back into that what about a reality
show because bryce
and seems to be wanting a reality show
to happen
about your guys's life our lives are
pretty hectic and crazy
um so i mean i'm sure the the
reality show would be awesome it would
probably
kill you you'd be on board oh yeah